[Music]
and finally AI generated pornography is
rapidly On The Rise according to
researchers you could as some American
teenage boys did recently put the faces
of the women that you know on sexually
explicit content and for it to look very
real indeed The Spectator Sam leth has
written about this for coffee house this
week and in an industry wrapped up in
sexual exploitation human trafficking
how could this change the future of porn
he joins me now alongside feminist
writer and campaigner Julie
bindle Sam and Julie welcome to
spectator TV now Sam for coffee house
this week you've written about the rise
of AI porn can you explain what you mean
by AI porn and how fast that rise has
been well it's it's the sort of
pornography of the no humans involved
variety where what AI has become really
really good at it turns out is kind of
creating out of a compost of billions of
images and God knows you know the
internet is 80% poor and anyway it's got
all these billions of images available
to it and it trains the AI to create new
images lifelike um you know lifelike
scenes and videos involving you know
essentially completely generated people
um I mean actually what sparked my
interest in it this week was that there
was a piece in I think Wall Street
Journal saying that this stuff was being
used for blackmail um in the sense that
people you know this of old revenge porn
thing people say I've got an intimate
compromising photograph of you or a
video of you having sex I'm going to
send it to all your friends unless you
give me a Bitcoin or I'm going going
know shame you or bully you with it and
what had happened is that now ai can
generate effectively fake nudes of real
people by either you know taking clothed
photographs of them and extrapolating
from that or simply kind of seamlessly
putting their face onto existing
pornographic footage um so it's kind of
it's quite alarming what the technology
can do and according to the Wall Street
Journal it's causing the people on the
receiving end of this some real distress
now Julie you spent so much of your life
campaigning against porn uh and violence
against women and girls what do you make
off this rise of AI
porn well I disagree with some that it's
a porn with no humans involved and I'll
just give another example of why I think
that this causes real harm um and in
fact is is is way more Insidious in many
ways than we could imagine I was at a
few years ago I went to the LA porn
Awards didn't win anything but there you
go I was reporting on it and there was
um there was a new product on sale at
the time which was sex dolls very
realistic porn dolls sex dolls which
whatever you want to call them made um a
very like life images of famous female
porn actors that men could buy so that
they are just effectively having sex
with violating abusing the Effigy of a
real person and some of the porn actors
told me that they found it really
distressing there was nothing they could
do about it now if we look at AI
generated porn it's not just being used
for blackmail it's also being used as
sex therapy which is the most abor thing
that I can imagine first of all the
notion that there are these men who are
hardwired as so-called pedophiles which
is nonsense it's a cultural uh Norm not
a hardwired genetic there's no there's
no pedophile Gene um
so what what the AI creators or the AI
apologists are saying is that if you
actually create child abuse imagery that
doesn't involve real harm to real
children these men will be satisfied as
though there are these men that have a
craving for sex with children that has
to be satisfied in a way that the
alcoholic has to have a drink this is a
myth and it seeks to just normalize the
suedes of men that do see out child
abuse imagery from the kind of school
girl in a uniform whether she's 16 18 or
14 through to hardcore stuff and
actually using AI child abuse imagery is
like pouring petrol on an already
flaming fire because what in fact it
does is desensitizes men because it
usually almost always is men to the
notion that children even babies are
being sexually abused because they can
justify by saying well of course I'm not
really harming children but I'm curious
because the way the porn trade Works its
money model is to push more and more
harder harder raise the bar all the time
so more money is spent but another thing
is and this perhaps is the most
concerning that men have a readymade
excuse use if they are found with child
abuse imagery to say well of course
these are AI created or at least that's
what I was told and AI creators of child
abuse imagery or the illegal horn which
would be illegal if it's been done to
real women uh in real time could also
Market it as though this is AI generated
so all it does is drive more traffic to
the most abusive imagery and absolutely
fuels the fire already raging Sam no I'm
I'm intrigued by that I don't think I
was was intending to imply when I said
no humans involved that this was you
know all Ticky boo and I think I Julie
maybe I'm getting ahead of myself we
we're talking about images of child
abuse for instance I mean it struck
me that there's sort of two ends to this
and you you know and abs yield to you
and your expertise on how they connect
one of which is it seems to me that you
know the real life abuse that takes
place in the creation of old school slow
food porn which you have admirably made
it you know your business to find out
about and investigate and expose over
many many
years and the other is what you
described the fuel on the fire that the
imagery helps to cultivate to normalize
to encourage appetites and they are
often appetites for more and more
extreme material for you know the taboo
I mean there does seem to be a thing
whereby the more taboo something is the
more people or some people are going to
find it sexy and that therefore the you
know that's why the the sort of Baseline
constantly moving and it struck me as a
thought experiment what I was writing
about in my piece was look if a lot of
mainstream pornography and I'm leaving
to one side for a second if you like
rape and child rape and that sort of
really extreme end of it but if the you
know your basic basic work a day
ordinary vanilla filth such as it is
were to be generated so cheaply and
effectively by
AI would that have at least at one end
of this this two-ended issue um the
effect of essentially removing some of
the market for the more
expensive real person
exploitative you know traditional porn
if you like where people are setting up
Studios they're trafficking and
exploiting very often you know the
performers there you know there's all
sorts of risk and consent issues and you
know there's a lot a lot of really
really nasty stuff goes on in the real
world as a result would do you think you
know leaving aside the question of the
appetites that the extreme stuff might
fuel which I'm very much not brushing
aside but leaving that to one
side is there a case that you know AI
porn might help to put a dent in an
industry that does an awful lot of real
world
harm well first of all Sam I wasn't for
a second thinking that you were actually
advocating for more AI porn that isn't
how I read the piece at all in fact I
thought it was a very very carefully
argued piece that asked some absolutely
crucial questions and I thought it was
it was very very uh nuanced and
responsibly written um but first of all
the best business model that the porn
industry ever came up with was free
porn um which actually puts a dent in
the argument about AI porn put in a dent
in the kind of pay for business because
what free porn did was it normalized the
use of porn for those that were not
thinking of themselves at that time as
porn consumers and that included
children so 11-year-old boys or it
included men who aren't disrespectful of
women who do have quite healthy real
life sex lives um with real life women
that's consensual but who thought well
I'll give it a bit of a whirl and of
course they're not going to put their
credit card um into the um the app
they're going to just start off on the
free porn and then of course and I don't
buy the addiction model I disagree with
those feminists that suggest that it's
addictive I do think that it gets
compulsive and I know the way that the
business model pushes and pushes just
that kind of more and more extreme their
Al your algorithms are very carefully
monitored and then you given something a
bit more risque are a bit more close to
illegality a bit more close to looking
as though it might be child abuse imagy
and then of course the credit cards can
come out so I think that that's that's a
problem with the arguments about AI um
because what AI will do is exactly what
um legal brothel for example at the
other side of the sex trade do for the
illegal industry it acts as a smoke
screen it acts as a driver and it acts
as a Gateway now not a Gateway in the
way that people are argue that cannabis
is a gateway to heroin I don't buy that
at all what I mean is that because there
isn't and this is my main argument there
isn't such a thing as a pedophile the
medical model that's hardwired to want
to have sex with children or rape
children rather this means that it's a
cultural drive and the more we normalize
it and of course AI will will rely it's
B its business will rely on child abuse
imetry within the next five years it
will be almost totally child abuse
imetry so we're we're driving more and
more men to the more normalized version
and as I say an excuse that they thought
it was all just Ai and no child was
could possibly have been harmed uh in
the meantime and Sam can I come in here
because um you also suggest that this is
a genie out of the bottle so do you
think that nothing can be done basically
to regulate this to to turn back the
tide it seems to me if you look at the
world's track record you know country by
country internationally in regulating
almost anything on the internet um it's
pretty poor I mean you know the the
protocols of the Elders of Zion are
still zooming around the internet the um
you know fake news has proliferated
rather than disappearing this whole idea
that sunlight is the best disinfectant
and a completely open internet will mean
that you know that everything will be
transparent and we'll all be able to see
the truth turned out to be the exact
opposite of the truth so you know if we
can't get rid of you know fake Gandy
quotes um the chances that we can get
rid of you know artificially
generated which can be done at scale of
course you know an AI can produce a you
know hour and a half long porn film I'm
assuming um or certainly will soon be
able to in a matter of moments and it
will be able to change it and it will be
able to put whoever you want in it and
it will be you know the idea that the
slow laborious business of copyright law
and takedowns and international
jurisdictions is going to going to be
able to handle this seems to me to be a
very very optimistic one Julie you must
be very concerned about that because at
least in the current form of the porn
industry you've got these major Studios
you've got the major companies you've
got the major websites that you can kind
of track but what we're seeing here is
you know kids teenagers and just your
average normal people taking this
technology and they have the capability
of creating that well SS absolutely
right you know the the internet is not
not pable but it is very difficult to do
so but there has to be the willingness
also I mean in countries like Sweden and
Norway and various others where um for
example the purchase of sex prostituted
sex has been criminalized police have
got pretty good at having a look on the
internet and tracking down gangs of
pimps and uh sexual exploitation in
general and I think that they could do
more than they're doing and I'm not a
kind of ban it all you know make make it
all illegal because actually we're
starting off from the point where there
is a proliferation and we need to think
much more closely about the way that we
have normalized um sexual abuse imagery
in general not just of children but of
adult women and men across the board and
what that means in terms of
relationships what it means in terms of
consensual sexual encounters when in
fact sex dolls porn dolls are becoming
way more um you know normalized
throughout that kind of industry but I
just want to flip it the other way
around in a way because we've got
AI obviously because of
technological progress at the end of um
a Spate of of of pornography being
available pretty much everywhere I mean
porn now actually drives technology
rather than the other way around where
we now have permission for more violent
degrading abusive rape porn um gagging
choking the kind of porn that that is is
way way more kind of acceptable than it
was 20 years ago partly because the
pornographers tested the market by using
cartoon imagery and if we think about
Hustler the infamous cover of Hustler
Magazine with a cartoon image of a woman
being put head first through a meat
grinder to
um you know to to depict her as just a
piece of meat that was there as you know
or a set of orisses for men to do what
they wanted with it was extremely
effective there are other images that
were tried um and tested in Playboy
which I can't even describe on this um
podcast because it's it's too
distressing which because it was cartoon
form they got away with it now we're in
a situation where AI will be able to go
way way further and remember many men
many consumers of Hardcore violent porn
enjoy their subject being abused they
enjoy the sadistic pleasure they want to
see them hurt and the thing about an AI
image an AI model is they know that
there's no pain being felt and that that
is something that will drive them back
and forth from AI back to the point
involving real life women being abused
on set now Julie what about the role of
payment systems and the companies like
uh MasterCard Visa PayPal for example
because I've read that their support uh
and they're cutting off of their support
for websites like PornHub has actually
really damaged pornhub's traffic because
the payment companies deemed what they
were doing as a bit too extreme and that
has actually had quite a real impact so
is that the way to regulate the industry
it absolutely could and in fact if you
look at what happened a couple of years
ago with mindgeek and PornHub which is
one of the uh sites that uh mindgeek own
the biggest porn site porn business on
the planet it was really successful when
after a huge out outcry from those of us
that do campaign to expose porn's
reality the hell of it where there were
countless videos uploaded of girls not
just women girls being raped and
otherwise abused when that all came out
thanks to the campaigning and the
exposure several big credit card
companies bowed to pressure and said
okay we won't accept payments through
PornHub it needs to clean up its act and
this is unacceptable and then of course
bit by bit it's crept back so that now
the big credit card companies are now
accepting payment so we need to keep the
pressure on but I think practically
that's the only thing we can do there's
no resources in policing and there's no
willingness and most police officers
male police officers are consuming porn
quite frankly and not only that but what
hurts the pornographers is the cash
being um you know that their revenue is
threatened in any way What Turns Point
pornographers on is not the sex it's the
cash and that's where we need to to
direct all our efforts Julie you'll have
chapter and verse on this but I remember
there was a kind of really shocking
thing that broke through about PornHub
that people started looking to its
system for flagging images of abuse
trafficked people stolen images rape all
these you underage underage participants
and there was a whole thing where I
think they had literally one person for
this entire site I remind me if I'm
getting this right who was supposedly in
charge of takedowns and nothing would be
brought to their attention unless it had
already been flagged three times by
three separate people regardless of what
it was is that right am I getting that
right that that's exactly right I can't
remember if it was one person or one and
a half people on a job share but it was
a scandal and I interviewed a a young
woman who when she was 15 was gang raped
and that that video of her gang rape was
up on PornHub and it was only after
years of her complaining begging writing
letters emailing getting her friends and
her parents to do so that finally a
lawyer came on board sent a legal letter
uh and they decided to take the um the
video down and that was some time that
she had to fight for that to happen that
should be instant and day Reger and they
can also of course filter they can vet
these videos in in reality mine geek
PornHub and and these big sites they
know that those rape videos Drive
traffic they know that they do this is
not there is no such thing as ethical
porn there is some porn that's less bad
than other porn genres but there is no
ethical porn and there is no ethical
porn industry Julie and Sam that's all
we have time for today thank you so much
for joining spectator
[Music]
TV